No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs to help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没人去汉克店里是为了看他的电子表格，大家去是为了吃那美味的披萨。不过最近店里冷清了不少。于是汉克决定重新推出1美元一片的披萨。他请微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，看看自己是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及哪些小细节能让1美元披萨的方案行得通。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. If you listen to the news or to political pundits, you've probably heard that Americans are more politically polarized than ever before. We've sorted ourselves into opposing red and blue camps and we can't seem to see eye to eye on anything. With Election Day around the corner, many of us are feeling the strain of those divisions. When you're getting into an angry debate with a childhood friend on Facebook or biting your tongue in a family dinner to keep the peace, the political divide can feel unbridgeable.
现在，汉克的店门口排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。访问M365Copilot.com/work了解更多。如果你听新闻或关注政治评论员，你可能听说过美国人比以往任何时候都更加政治极化。我们把自己分成了红蓝对立的阵营，似乎在任何事情上都无法达成共识。随着选举日临近，我们许多人都感受到了这些分歧带来的压力。当你和儿时好友在Facebook上进行激烈的争论，或者在家庭聚餐时为了维持和平而忍气吞声时，这种政治鸿沟会让人觉得无法逾越。
Amid that strain, psychologists' research can offer some insight. It can help us understand where our political identities come from, why we think about politics the way we do, and why it's so hard to talk across the political divide. So what is the psychology that underlies how most people think about politics? How did American history and our own places in it lead each of us where we are? Is the political divide today really worse than it was years ago? Does social media cause political polarization or does it just reflect it?
在这种压力下，心理学家的研究或许能提供一些见解。它能帮助我们理解我们的政治认同从何而来，为什么我们以这种方式思考政治，以及为什么跨越政治鸿沟进行对话如此困难。那么，大多数人思考政治背后的心理机制是什么？美国历史以及我们在其中的位置是如何将我们每个人带到今天的？今天的政治分歧真的比多年前更严重吗？社交媒体是导致政治极化的原因，还是仅仅反映了这种极化？
And what can we do to bridge the divide and maintain connections with those we disagree with? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Keith Payne, a professor of psychology at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill. Dr. Payne is a social psychologist who studies inequality and political polarization. His work has been featured in the New York Times and the Atlantic and on NPR. He's author of the 2017 book, The Broken Ladder, How Inequality Effects the Way We Live, Think and Die.
我们能做些什么来弥合分歧并与意见不同的人保持联系？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的心理学教授基思·佩恩（Dr. Keith Payne）博士。佩恩博士是一位研究不平等和政治极化的社会心理学家。他的作品曾被《纽约时报》、《大西洋月刊》和美国国家公共电台（NPR）报道。他还是2017年出版的《破碎的阶梯：不平等如何影响我们的生活、思考和死亡》（The Broken Ladder, How Inequality Effects the Way We Live, Think and Die）一书的作者。
His new book, coming out in October, is called Good, Reasonable People, The Psychology Behind America's Dangerous Divide. Dr. Payne, thank you for joining me today. Well, thanks so much for having me. Your new book starts with a very personal note. It opens with stories about your childhood in Kentucky. Can you tell us a little bit about your background and how it led to your interest in polarization? Yeah, so I grew up in a small town in western Kentucky, a town called Macyo that has about 400
他的新书将于十月出版，书名为《善良、理性的人：美国危险分歧背后的心理学》（Good, Reasonable People, The Psychology Behind America's Dangerous Divide）。佩恩博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。您的新书以非常私人的基调开篇，讲述了您在肯塔基州童年的故事。您能谈谈您的背景以及它是如何让您对极化产生兴趣的吗？好的，我在肯塔基州西部的一个小镇长大，那个镇叫梅西奥（Macyo），大约有400
people that is, I believe, as of the recent census count, still, 100% white and has very little diversity when I was growing up, overwhelmingly conservative, white, and Christian. And the kinds of dynamics that I saw growing up within my family, during especially starting around the 1990s, where some people started to pull away from the way that other people in my community tended to think, I thought that was just something that was happening. in my family, something that was happening in my little town. And it turned out over time, I started to realize that those were the same kinds of divides that were happening across the country as a whole. So people were sorting themselves more and more based on factors like
人。据我所知，根据最近的人口普查，那里仍然是100%的白人，我成长过程中那里几乎没有什么多样性，绝大多数是保守派、白人和基督徒。我在成长过程中看到的家庭内部的动态，特别是在20世纪90年代开始，有些人开始远离社区中其他人倾向的思考方式，我当时以为这只是发生在我家庭、发生在我小镇上的事情。但随着时间的推移，我开始意识到，这些正是全国范围内正在发生的分歧。所以人们越来越多地根据诸如
race and religion and education. And I started to see those cleavages happening within my own family. And as polarization became more and more intense and emotional and widespread over the last 20 or 30 years, I've been drawn to look more and more closely at the psychology of it and what's happening at a broader level. There's a quote in your new book that struck me, which is, there is no liberal mind or conservative mind. There are only human minds trying to make sense of the circumstances in which they find themselves. That idea goes against what I think many of us believe, which is that there are real differences between liberals and conservatives in terms of personality or other attributes. Can you explain what you meant by that and what the research is behind that statement?
种族、宗教和教育等因素进行自我分类。我开始看到这些裂痕在我自己的家庭中出现。随着过去二三十年来极化变得越来越强烈、情绪化和普遍，我被吸引去更深入地观察其背后的心理学以及在更广泛层面上发生的事情。您的新书中有一句话让我印象深刻，那就是：“没有所谓的自由派头脑或保守派头脑。只有人类的头脑在试图理解他们所处的环境。”这个观点与我们许多人的认知相悖，我们认为自由派和保守派在性格或其他属性上存在真正的差异。您能解释一下您的意思以及这一陈述背后的研究依据吗？
There's definitely differences between liberals and conservatives or Democrats and Republicans in terms of what they think, the content of their beliefs and their attitudes. But in terms of the basic psychology behind how we make sense. of politics, how we make sense of our social worlds more broadly, we are all working with the same hardware, right? We've all got the same kinds of minds. And what we're doing is we're living in different circumstances, different social worlds, different geographies often. And what we're all doing is trying to make sense of that world from the perspective of the social groups and the contexts that we belong to. So there is a lot of research. about the relationship between personality and political differences, and there are some personality
自由派和保守派，或者民主党人和共和党人在他们的想法、信仰和态度的内容上确实存在差异。但就我们如何理解政治、如何更广泛地理解我们的社会世界的心理基础而言，我们都在使用相同的硬件，对吧？我们都有着相同类型的头脑。我们所做的是生活在不同的环境、不同的社会世界、通常是不同的地理位置中。我们都在做的是从我们所属的社会群体和背景的角度来理解这个世界。所以有很多关于性格与政治差异之间关系的研究，而且民主党人和共和党人之间平均而言确实存在一些性格
differences between Democrats and Republicans on average. For example, Democrats or liberals tend to be higher in a trait called openness to experience. There are a few other personality traits that consistently correlate with political differences. But the thing to keep in mind is those differences are quite small. They're not zero. They're real. But it amounts to showing that Democrats are a few percentage points higher on a trait like openness to experience than Republicans. Republicans might be a few percentage points higher on traits like the need for structure or need to think about things in a clear structured way. But those few percentage points that separate liberals and conservatives on those personality dimensions don't go anywhere close
差异。例如，民主党人或自由派在“开放性”这一特质上往往得分更高。还有一些其他性格特质与政治差异持续相关。但需要记住的是，这些差异非常小。它们不是零，它们是真实的。但这相当于显示民主党人在“开放性”等特质上比共和党人高出几个百分点。共和党人在“对结构的需求”或“以清晰结构化的方式思考事物的需求”等特质上可能会高出几个百分点。但这些将自由派和保守派在性格维度上区分开来的几个百分点，根本不足以
to explaining the giant gulfs we see between people based on their social groups, based on social identities, which are often tied to these demographic differences. Now, you make the point in the book that people think that political polarization is about policy disagreements and different philosophies. But really, as you were just saying, they're about identity. Can you elaborate on that more? When we talk about political ideology, what we're talking about is a coherent set of political principles or at least an interrelated set of values and issue stands. That's what we mean when I say to somebody has a liberal ideology or a conservative ideology.
解释我们基于社会群体、基于社会认同（通常与这些人口统计学差异相关）在人们之间看到的巨大鸿沟。您在书中指出，人们认为政治极化是关于政策分歧和不同哲学观点的。但实际上，正如您刚才所说，它们是关于认同的。您能详细说明一下吗？当我们谈论政治意识形态时，我们谈论的是一套连贯的政治原则，或者至少是一套相互关联的价值观和立场。这就是我所说的某人具有自由派意识形态或保守派意识形态的意思。
But social scientists have known since at least the 1960s that if you look at the actual views of the American public, they don't. tend to fall along any consistent ideological lines when it comes to issues and political principles. So if you look at somebody's attitude toward one issue like tax cuts or tax increases and you look at their attitudes toward other issues like government spending or government budget cuts, you would think that logically those two things would be connected to each other. but they're actually very weakly correlated with each other when we look at real people's polling or survey data. And if you look at the same person's responses over time, if you ask them the exact same question about a policy issue or a political principle,
但社会科学家至少从20世纪60年代就知道，如果你观察美国公众的实际观点，当涉及到议题和政治原则时，它们并不倾向于沿着任何一致的意识形态路线排列。所以，如果你观察某人对一个议题（如减税或增税）的态度，再观察他们对其他议题（如政府支出或政府预算削减）的态度，你会认为从逻辑上讲这两者是相互关联的，但当我们观察真实人群的民意调查或调查数据时，它们之间的相关性实际上非常微弱。如果你观察同一个人随时间推移的反应，如果你问他们关于政策议题或政治原则的完全相同的问题，
they often give you a very different response six months or a year later. So they don't even agree with themselves very well. And political scientists have estimated that if you think of an ideation, as a coherent and stable interconnected set of ideas, only about 15% of the American public has what would qualify as an ideology in that sense. The vast majority of us, about 85%, don't have what we would really consider an ideology. What we have instead is a social identity. We know who our people are. We might identify strongly with one political party or the other, and we might really dislike that the other
他们六个月或一年后给出的回答往往非常不同。所以他们甚至不能很好地与自己达成一致。政治学家估计，如果你把意识形态看作是一套连贯、稳定且相互关联的思想，那么只有大约15%的美国公众拥有符合这种定义的意识形态。我们绝大多数人，大约85%，并没有我们真正认为的意识形态。我们拥有的是社会认同。我们知道谁是“我们的人”。我们可能强烈认同某一个政党，我们也可能非常讨厌另一个
group, but those sentiments are tied much more closely to our social group identities than to anything about policy or political philosophy. And all of this would seem to add up to the fact that political polling is very imprecise, right? I mean, people will answer the same question differently on a different day of the week. Yeah, it could be that polling is imprecise, but I think probably more than that, at least polling, we know we can quantify how imprecise it is. We have a margin of error.
群体，但这些情绪与我们的社会群体认同的联系远比与政策或政治哲学相关的联系紧密得多。所有这些似乎都说明政治民调非常不精确，对吧？我的意思是，人们在不同的一周里会对同一个问题给出不同的回答。是的，民调可能是不精确的，但我认为可能不仅如此，至少对于民调，我们知道我们可以量化它的不精确程度。我们有误差范围。
And so we can estimate how off we are likely to be. The thing is, I think when people are inconsistent over time, it's usually because they're giving us the best answer they have at time one. And then when we contact them a year later, they're giving us the best answer they have at time two. And those aren't always very stable. I think a lot of it comes down to the fact that those of us who are more, reading and writing and talking about politics all the time,
所以我们可以估计我们可能偏离了多少。问题在于，我认为当人们随时间推移表现出不一致时，通常是因为他们在第一个时间点给出了他们当时能给出的最好答案。然后当我们一年后联系他们时，他们给出了他们在第二个时间点能给出的最好答案。而这些答案并不总是非常稳定。我认为很大程度上是因为我们这些更多地阅读、写作和谈论政治的人，
assume that everybody else is a political junkie like us. So the so-called elites like journalists and academics and political leaders themselves, we eat and sleep and breed this stuff, and we assume that other people do as well. But that's just not true. It's not that central or meaningful in the daily lives of most people. And so imagine if you called people up and just assumed that they had detailed opinions about classical music or something that's esoteric to most ordinary people. And you ask them detailed questions about their preferences and attitudes in the area of classical music.
假设其他人也像我们一样是政治迷。所以所谓的精英，如记者、学者和政治领导人本身，我们吃、睡、呼吸这些东西，我们假设其他人也一样。但这根本不是事实。它在大多数人的日常生活中并不那么核心或有意义。所以想象一下，如果你给人们打电话，仅仅假设他们对古典音乐或大多数普通人觉得深奥的东西有详细的见解。然后你问他们关于古典音乐领域偏好和态度的详细问题。
A lot of times people would give you an answer, but it might not mean anything. It might just be what they're thinking at the moment. And then if you called them up a year later and asked them a question again, they're probably not going to be. I have a consistent opinion on that because it's not something they spend their time thinking about. In your new book, you also talk about what you're calling the psychological immune system and how we use it to validate what we already believe. And you also talk about something called motivated reasoning. So can you talk about those two concepts, how they're different, how they're the same, and how we use them? Right. So motivated reasoning is the idea that whenever we're thinking
很多时候人们会给你一个答案，但这可能毫无意义。这可能只是他们当时的想法。然后如果你一年后给他们打电话再次问他们一个问题，他们可能不会有一个一致的观点，因为这不是他们花时间思考的事情。在您的新书中，您还谈到了所谓的“心理免疫系统”，以及我们如何利用它来验证我们已经相信的东西。您还谈到了所谓的“动机性推理”。那么您能谈谈这两个概念吗？它们有何不同，有何相同，以及我们如何使用它们？好的。所以动机性推理是指每当我们思考
and reasoning. We're not just reasoning for the purpose of finding truth. That's one thing we're trying to do. We're trying to find true answers about the world. But another thing we're trying to do at the same time is to reassure ourselves that we're good and reasonable people. And that's where the name for the book comes from. So a lot of the thinking we do is aimed at reassuring ourselves that we're good members of our social group, that we're good and reasonable people. And the people in our groups that mean a lot to us are as well. So motivated reason, is one of the main mechanisms that we deploy in what I've called the or what psychologists have called the psychological immune system. The idea behind
和推理时，我们不仅仅是为了寻找真理而推理。这是我们试图做的一件事。我们试图找到关于世界的真实答案。但与此同时，我们试图做的另一件事是向自己保证我们是善良且理性的人。这就是书名的由来。所以我们所做的很多思考都是为了向自己保证我们是社会群体中优秀的成员，我们是善良且理性的人。并且我们群体中对我们意义重大的那些人也是如此。所以动机性推理是我们部署在心理免疫系统中的主要机制之一。心理免疫系统背后的
the psychological immune system is that we have a suite of psychological processes, thought processes that we use to defend our sense of self as a good and reasonable member of our groups akin to the way that the biological immune system destroys biological threats to the body. So the psychological immune system is similar to other ideas in psychology like coping with stress or defense mechanisms from an older Freudian point of view. It's the ways that we go about coming up with interpretations of new information, rationalizations, and justifications for whatever we do or say or think to interpret all that in a way that adds up to this psychological bottom line that I'm a good and reasonable person. And is that different from confirmation bias? Because as I was reading the book, I was thinking, you know, there's definitely a relationship going on here that people find information. They accept it. They ingest it. They believe it because it comports with things that they were already thinking. Confirmation bias is one of the tools we use for sure. So confirmation bias is the tendency to look for or generate evidence that's consistent with ideas that we already believed are true. So that's definitely.
想法是，我们拥有一套心理过程，即我们用来捍卫自己作为群体中善良且理性成员的自我感的思维过程，这类似于生物免疫系统摧毁对身体的生物威胁的方式。所以心理免疫系统类似于心理学中的其他概念，比如应对压力或老派弗洛伊德观点中的防御机制。它是我们用来对新信息进行解释、合理化和辩护的方式，无论我们做什么、说什么或想什么，都要以一种能得出“我是一个善良且理性的人”这一心理底线的方式来解释这一切。这与确认偏误不同吗？因为我在读这本书时，我在想，你知道，这里肯定存在一种关系，人们找到信息，他们接受它，他们摄入它，他们相信它，因为这符合他们已经想到的事情。确认偏误当然是我们使用的工具之一。所以确认偏误是寻找或产生与我们已经认为真实的想法一致的证据的倾向。所以这绝对是
only one tool that we use as part of the psychological immune system, as part of this idea of motivated reasoning. But the psychological immune system is broader than that. Sometimes it can be confirmation bias that serves the goal of reassuring us that we're a good person. Sometimes it's changing our opinion and taking on the new opinion, maybe a social group that means a lot to us, if that's what makes us feel like a good member of that group. I was just wondering, again, as I was reading the book, whether you believe that it's actually possible to change other people's opinions? Well, I think it's possible for people's opinions to change.
我们作为心理免疫系统一部分、作为动机性推理这一理念一部分所使用的工具之一。但心理免疫系统比这更广泛。有时它可以是服务于向自己保证我们是一个好人这一目标的确认偏误。有时它是改变我们的观点并采纳新观点，也许是一个对我们意义重大的社会群体，如果这让我们感觉自己是该群体中优秀的成员的话。我只是在想，再次阅读这本书时，您是否认为真的有可能改变其他人的观点？嗯，我认为人们的观点是有可能改变的。
That's not the same thing as saying it's possible to change other people's opinions. Psychologists talk about something called the cognitive response principle, which is the idea that any time you present information or an argument or a persuasive attempt to somebody to try to change what they believe, they never change in response to that external influence that you've tried to to exert. If they change, it's because they've generated cognitive responses, thoughts of their own that they then listen to and change based on their own inner thought processes. So, for example, if you try to change somebody's opinion and their internal monologue is, well, that's a crazy argument. That doesn't make any sense at all. Then your attempt is probably going to backfire
这与说“改变其他人的观点是有可能的”不是一回事。心理学家谈论一种叫做“认知反应原则”的东西，即每当你向某人提供信息、论点或试图说服他们以改变他们的信仰时，他们永远不会因为你试图施加的外部影响而改变。如果他们改变了，那是因为他们产生了认知反应，即他们自己的想法，然后他们听取这些想法并根据自己的内心思维过程进行改变。所以，例如，如果你试图改变某人的观点，而他们的内心独白是：“嗯，那是一个疯狂的论点。那根本说不通。”那么你的尝试很可能会适得其反，
because you presented them with arguments for X and their thoughts are that X is false. So they're going to listen to their own thoughts. And in that case, they're not going to change their opinion. Maybe they're even more opposed to your argument than they were before. But if you're in a circumstance where you provide people with an argument or a persuasive attempt and their cognitive of response to that is positive, then they might change their opinion based on their own thought processes. So every time we try to change somebody else's opinion, we're just setting an occasion for them to generate their own arguments and listen to themselves. Have you ever rearranged your furniture and discovered the carpet underneath looks brand new while the rest of it looks,
因为你向他们提出了支持X的论点，而他们的想法是X是错误的。所以他们会听从自己的想法。在这种情况下，他们不会改变自己的观点。也许他们比以前更反对你的论点。但如果你处于这样一种情况：你向人们提供了一个论点或说服尝试，而他们对此的认知反应是积极的，那么他们可能会根据自己的思维过程改变观点。所以每次我们试图改变别人的观点时，我们只是在为他们创造一个机会，让他们产生自己的论点并听从自己。你有没有重新摆放过家具，发现下面的地毯看起来焕然一新，而其余部分看起来，
well, not so new? It's time for a carpet upgrade. At the Home Depot, we have stylish choices at simple prices from all the top brands. Best of all, we can install it for you, starting at only 49 cents per square foot. So all you have to do is pick your perfect floor. Start your carpet project today at the Home Depot. How doers get more done. Exclusions apply for licenses, see Home Depot.com slash license numbers. You go back into the early history of the United States to explain many of our historical
嗯，没那么新了？是时候升级地毯了。在家得宝（The Home Depot），我们以简单的价格提供来自所有顶级品牌的时尚选择。最棒的是，我们可以为您安装，每平方英尺仅需49美分起。所以您所要做的就是挑选您完美的地板。今天就开始您的地毯项目吧，在家得宝。实干家成就更多。排除条款适用于许可，请参阅HomeDepot.com/license numbers。您回顾了美国早期历史来解释我们的许多历史
divisions. How has that history contributed to the divisions we're seeing today? So when we look around us and try to make sense of the world, a lot depends on the arrangements and the systems and the group statuses that are in that environment around us. And those circumstances and those systems have been put into place by historical processes that started long before we were born. One of the factors that I look at in the book is the way that the United States Civil War and the Reconcelebring, period following the Civil War, set up systems and structures related to racial inequality, especially in the South, the resistance to racial equality during the reconstruction period. So you can look at census data on the number of people who were enslaved in each county
分歧。那段历史是如何导致我们今天看到的分歧的？所以当我们环顾四周并试图理解这个世界时，很大程度上取决于我们周围环境中的安排、系统和群体地位。而这些环境和系统是由远在我们出生前就开始的历史进程所建立的。我在书中研究的因素之一是美国内战以及内战后的重建时期，如何建立了与种族不平等相关的系统和结构，特别是在南方，以及重建时期对种族平等的抵制。所以你可以查看人口普查数据，了解每个县被奴役的人数
on the eve of the Civil War in 1860. And political scientists have found that that is a good point. predictor of white Americans' political leanings today. And the connection, in my view, is that those places that were more dependent on slavery in 1860, during the period following the Civil War, set up systems that were more unequal, more segregated by race, led to Jim Crow segregation for about 100 years. and those places are still more racially unequal today. And it's not just a broad north-south difference.
在1860年内战前夕。政治学家发现，这是今天美国白人政治倾向的一个很好的预测指标。在我看来，这种联系在于，那些在1860年更依赖奴隶制的地区，在内战后的时期，建立了更不平等、种族隔离更严重的系统，导致了长达约100年的吉姆·克劳法（Jim Crow）种族隔离。而这些地方今天在种族上仍然更加不平等。这不仅仅是广泛的南北差异。
You can look county to county, and those places that had more slavery because the soil was more favorable to growing cotton versus the county next door that might have had a geography that didn't favor growing cotton. You can see county-to-county differences today in the politics of the white-and-black residents
你可以逐县查看，那些拥有更多奴隶的地方，因为土壤更适合种植棉花，而隔壁的县可能地理条件不利于种植棉花。你今天可以在这些县的白人和黑人居民的政治中看到县与县之间的差异。
in those counties. So what seems to be happening is that people don't on a general day-to-day basis go around thinking about what was happening in 1860. What they do is look around them today. And in places that have a lot of racial inequality, the average white American tends to interpret that as something not about history and systems that have led to disadvantages for black Americans. they tend to interpret that as something about current day motivations and behaviors of white and black Americans. So white Americans today who live in a place that used to have a lot of slavery tend to think that racial inequality is due to black Americans not working as hard. And that is highly correlated with Republican identity, whereas in those same areas, those same counties with lots of racial inequality today, black Americans, tend to interpret that same racial inequality as something about the history and the systems of
所以似乎发生的情况是，人们在日常生活中并不会到处去思考1860年发生了什么。他们所做的是看看今天的周围。在种族不平等严重的地方，普通美国白人倾向于将其解释为与历史和导致美国黑人处于劣势的系统无关的事情。他们倾向于将其解释为与美国白人和黑人当前的动机和行为有关的事情。所以今天生活在曾经有大量奴隶制地区的美籍白人倾向于认为种族不平等是由于美国黑人工作不够努力。这与共和党身份高度相关，而在同一地区，在今天种族不平等严重的同一县，美国黑人倾向于将同样的种族不平等解释为与历史和
racial discrimination. And that is highly correlated with the democratic identity. So given how polarized everything was at that point in our history as we were talking about the Civil War and Reconstruction, are we more or less polarized today? Is there any way of knowing whether qualitatively or quantitatively, it's different? Well, I don't know if we compare it to the Civil War, I would say we're probably at the most polarized in some ways than we have been since the Civil War and the aftermath. But whether we're more polarized today than we were, say, 30 or 40 years ago, depends on whether we're talking about polarization in terms of issues.
种族歧视系统有关。这与民主党身份高度相关。那么，考虑到我们历史中那个时刻的极化程度，正如我们谈论内战和重建时所说的那样，我们今天更极化还是更不极化了？有没有办法知道它是定性还是定量地不同？嗯，我不知道如果我们把它与内战相比，我会说在某些方面我们可能处于自内战及其后果以来最极化的状态。但我们今天是否比三四十年前更极化，取决于我们谈论的是议题方面的极化，
versus polarization in terms of group identities and emotions. Because if you look at issue stands and policy preferences, Republicans and Democrats today aren't very far apart. On the other hand, if you look at how strongly people identify with their political groups and how much antagonism they feel toward the other side, that has really grown over the last 30 or 40 years. Do you think that social media and partisan news channels are driving some of this polarization, or are they just reflecting the divisions that exist anyway?
还是群体认同和情感方面的极化。因为如果你看议题立场和政策偏好，今天的共和党人和民主党人相差并不远。另一方面，如果你看人们对他们政治群体的认同有多强烈，以及他们对另一方感到多少敌意，那在过去三四十年里确实增长了。您认为社交媒体和党派新闻频道正在推动这种极化，还是它们只是反映了无论如何都存在的分歧？
Well, one thing that social media and polarized news outlets do is magnified division that's there, make it easy to communicate and spread that polarization. But again, it depends on what exactly you mean by polarization here. So social media is very good at spreading outrage. And moral outrage in particular is something that makes a post more likely to go viral. So in that sense, social media is critical in the spread and possibly the growth of polarization. But if you look at other metrics that are often blamed on social media like the spread of misinformation and conspiracy theories, there the evidence is not so clear. I think the jury is still out on the role of social media in spreading that misinformation.
嗯，社交媒体和极化新闻媒体所做的一件事是放大了那里存在的分歧，使沟通和传播这种极化变得容易。但同样，这取决于你在这里所说的极化到底是什么意思。所以社交媒体非常擅长传播愤怒。尤其是道德义愤，是使帖子更有可能疯传的东西。所以从这个意义上说，社交媒体在极化的传播和可能的增长中至关重要。但如果你看其他经常被归咎于社交媒体的指标，比如错误信息和阴谋论的传播，那里的证据并不那么明确。我认为社交媒体在传播这些错误信息方面的作用尚无定论。
There's an interesting set of studies that recently came out looking at how Americans' beliefs in misinformation and conspiracy theories has changed over the last 30 or 40 years going back well before social media existed. And it turns out that the rate of beliefs in conspiracy theories has been roughly constant over the last 40 years. It's just that some conspiracy theories have fallen out of fashion and other conspiracy theories. have taken their place. We have this sense that social media is the driver of all of this fake information being spread around. But I think if that was the case, you would see a sharp rise in the overall beliefs in conspiracy theories over the last 10 years or so. And that just doesn't seem to be the case. Let's talk for a minute about your previous book, which was about inequality and how inequality affects how people think and behave. What's the role of inequality
最近出现了一系列有趣的研究，观察美国人对错误信息和阴谋论的信仰在过去三四十年里是如何变化的，追溯到社交媒体存在之前。结果发现，过去40年来，对阴谋论的信仰率大致保持不变。只是有些阴谋论已经过时了，而其他阴谋论取而代之。我们有一种感觉，社交媒体是所有这些虚假信息传播的驱动力。但我认为如果是这样的话，你会看到过去10年左右对阴谋论的总体信仰急剧上升。而事实似乎并非如此。让我们谈谈您之前的书，它是关于不平等以及不平等如何影响人们的思考和行为。不平等在推动极化中扮演什么角色？
in driving polarization? One of the effects of inequality increasing over the last 30 years is that, you know, there have always been the rich and the poor, but the rich and the poor are so much further apart from each other today than they were 30 years ago, right? So the richest five or 10 or 1% have drastically more money and wealth than they did in the 70s or even the 80s. And the coming apart of the relatively rich and the relatively poor has a number of consequences. They're social and health related, but also political.
过去30年不平等加剧的影响之一是，你知道，一直都有富人和穷人，但今天的富人和穷人比30年前相差得远得多，对吧？所以最富有的5%、10%或1%的人拥有的金钱和财富比他们在70年代甚至80年代时要多得多。而相对富裕和相对贫穷的人的分离产生了一系列后果。它们是社会和健康相关的，但也是政治性的。
And the chief effect that I think we see in terms of American politics is that when people find themselves either on a higher rung or a bottom rung of the socioeconomic ladder, they tend to justify and rationalize why it is that. they're there, right? So we've done studies, for example, that if we give people feedback, that they have more money and wealth than other people they know. And we ask them why that might be. So this is not necessarily people who actually do have more money, but we're giving them randomized feedback in a study. The typical response is to say, well, I worked hard and I earned that money. If we take identical group of people and tell them you have less money or less wealth than people like you. Why do you think that is? They look at the exact same situation and say, well, it's because the system is unfair and I was disadvantaged by the following rigged system.
我认为我们在美国政治方面看到的主要影响是，当人们发现自己处于社会经济阶梯的较高阶层或底层时，他们倾向于证明和合理化为什么他们会在那里，对吧？所以我们做过研究，例如，如果我们给人们反馈，说他们比他们认识的其他人都拥有更多的金钱和财富。我们问他们为什么会这样。所以这不一定是那些确实拥有更多钱的人，但我们在研究中给他们随机反馈。典型的反应是说：“嗯，我努力工作，我赚到了那些钱。”如果我们取一组相同的人，告诉他们：“你比像你这样的人拥有更少的钱或更少的财富。你认为这是为什么？”他们看着完全相同的情况说：“嗯，这是因为系统不公平，我被以下操纵的系统置于不利地位。”
And so people who end up on the top or the bottom of the economic ladder don't tend to attribute it to the luck of the draw or accidents of history. They tend to think, I'm a good and reasonable person. So here's how I must have gotten here, right? And fill in those blanks with various justifications and rationalizations. So one of the consequences of that is that when people either feel richer than others or are actually richer than others, they tend to think they earned it and they tend to oppose, you know, redistributive policies and policies meant to help the poor because they think, well, I earned this through hard work and so can other people. Whereas when people occupy lower socioeconomic rungs, they tend to think, well, the system is broken
所以那些最终处于经济阶梯顶端或底端的人，往往不会将其归因于运气或历史的偶然。他们倾向于认为：“我是一个善良且理性的人。所以这就是我一定是如何到达这里的，对吧？”并用各种辩护和合理化来填补这些空白。所以其后果之一是，当人们要么觉得比别人富有，要么实际上比别人富有，他们倾向于认为他们赚到了，并且他们倾向于反对，你知道，再分配政策和旨在帮助穷人的政策，因为他们认为：“嗯，我通过努力工作赚到了这些，其他人也可以。”而当人们占据较低的社会经济阶层时，他们倾向于认为：“嗯，系统坏了，
and it's creating disadvantages for me. So in that way, the rationalizations people come up with for their own economic status feed into what we believe about political groups and political policies. And as inequality arises and their richest 10% get further and further from the poorest 10% that just exacerbates those political differences that go along with income inequality. I thought it was really interesting that you talked to people with, in some cases, a lot of money and that they were still, they had a sense that they weren't really rich, they didn't really have quite enough, that there was this sense of dissatisfaction. And I'm wondering, does that conflict with the work of, say, Dan Gilbert, who found that if you make about $70-oddousand-a-dollar a year,
它正在为我制造劣势。”所以通过这种方式，人们为自己的经济地位想出的合理化解释，助长了我们对政治群体和政治政策的信仰。随着不平等加剧，最富有的10%与最贫穷的10%距离越来越远，这只会加剧那些伴随收入不平等而来的政治差异。我觉得很有趣的是，您与一些在某些情况下非常有钱的人交谈，他们仍然有一种感觉，他们并不是真的富有，他们并没有真正拥有足够的钱，有一种不满感。我想知道，这是否与丹·吉尔伯特（Dan Gilbert）等人的研究相冲突？他发现如果你一年赚大约7万多美元，
you don't get any happier than if you make a million dollars a year. So money makes a difference up to a certain point, like you said, in that research a few years ago, it was somewhere around 70,000. Maybe it would be a bit higher today. But yeah, there's this diminishing marginal return when you look at the relationship between money and happiness. And I think it's actually consistent with the idea that people adapt to where they are and start and keep comparing upward to those who have more.
你并不会比一年赚一百万美元更快乐。所以金钱在一定程度上确实有影响，就像您说的，在几年前的那项研究中，大约是7万左右。也许今天会高一点。但是的，当你观察金钱与幸福之间的关系时，存在这种边际效用递减。我认为这实际上与人们适应他们所处的位置，并开始并不断向上比较那些拥有更多的人这一观点是一致的。
So at some point, more money doesn't bring more happiness. And I think that's in part because once you've got, say, $200,000 a year and you're well above that threshold for increased happiness, you're comparing yourself not to people who make $60,000 anymore. Now you're comparing to people who make $500,000. And so there's this shifting upward comparison that happens as people make more money. And it's this fascinating, subjective, squishiness that comes along with the idea of having enough. It's a constantly moving target.
所以到了一定程度，更多的钱并不能带来更多的幸福。我认为这部分是因为一旦你有了，比如说，一年20万美元，并且你远高于那个幸福感增加的门槛，你就不再把自己与那些赚6万美元的人进行比较了。现在你是在与那些赚50万美元的人进行比较。所以随着人们赚更多的钱，这种向上的比较就会发生。这是一种迷人的、主观的、模糊的东西，伴随着“拥有足够”的概念。这是一个不断移动的目标。
Going back to the issue of polarization, do you have any advice or thoughts based on the work that you've done on how people can bridge the gap? Well, it's a difficult question, and I won't pretend to have easy answers to difficult questions. But here's what I think the research suggests. if we understand polarization as having to do with our social identities, and we understand that what people on both sides of the aisle are doing is trying to make sense of what my status is in society and the social groups I belong to and reassuring ourselves that we're good and reasonable people
回到极化问题，根据您所做的工作，您对人们如何弥合分歧有什么建议或想法吗？嗯，这是一个困难的问题，我不会假装对困难的问题有简单的答案。但这就是我认为研究表明的：如果我们理解极化与我们的社会认同有关，并且我们理解两党的人们所做的是试图理解我在社会中的地位以及我所属的社会群体，并向自己保证我们是善良且理性的人，
and good members of our groups, when we're tempted to get into an argument with your relative on Facebook or at the Thanksgiving dinner, et cetera, I think it helps to step away from just, trying to prove them wrong in terms of whatever argument they're making or whatever ideas they're sharing. And to ask the question, what are they trying to do here? How are they using politics or how are they using this argument to try to reassure themselves that they're a good and valuable person? And then take a step back and say, maybe I'm doing the same thing. How am I
并且是我们群体中优秀的成员，当我们想在Facebook上或感恩节晚餐时与亲戚争论时，等等，我认为退一步，不要仅仅试图在他们提出的任何论点或分享的任何想法方面证明他们是错的，这会有所帮助。而是要问这个问题：“他们在这里试图做什么？他们是如何利用政治或如何利用这个论点来试图向自己保证他们是一个善良且有价值的人的？”然后退后一步说：“也许我正在做同样的事情。我如何
using this argument to defend my sense that I'm a good and reasonable person? And it's not necessarily going to change either person's ideas about the political issue. But once you start interpreting that interaction as two people doing the best they can to reassure themselves that they're good and reasonable people, it's a very different conversation than if you're just focused narrowly on the political outrage of the moment. So last question, what's next for you on the research front? Are you, you have a new book percolating up there in your brain? No new book on the horizon yet. focused on this one at the moment. But I'm really interested in understanding how these larger scale historical forces, like the ones we were talking about, whether it's related to slavery and reconstruction, or later century, the Great Migration and other kinds of demographic and cultural and historical changes have set the stage for a lot of the psychological processes that we see going on now.
利用这个论点来捍卫我是一个善良且理性的人的感觉？”这不一定会改变任何人对政治议题的想法。但一旦你开始将那种互动解释为两个人都在尽最大努力向自己保证他们是善良且理性的人，这与你仅仅专注于当下的政治愤怒相比，就是一场非常不同的对话。所以最后一个问题，您的研究前沿接下来是什么？您的大脑中是否正在酝酿一本新书？目前还没有新书的计划。目前专注于这一本。但我真的很有兴趣了解这些更大规模的历史力量，比如我们谈论的那些，无论是与奴隶制和重建有关，还是后来的世纪，大迁徙以及其他种族、文化和历史变化，是如何为我们现在看到的许多心理过程奠定基础的。
So that relationship between history and sometimes very ancient history and current-based psychology is what I'm really focused on right now. All right. Well, Dr. Payne, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been a pleasure talking with you. Thanks so much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman.
所以历史与有时非常古老的历史以及当前心理学之间的那种关系，是我现在真正关注的。好的。好吧，佩恩博士，我想感谢您今天参加我的节目。与您交谈非常愉快。非常感谢您的邀请。您可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果您喜欢您所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver. it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order.
感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。放松一下，让拉尔夫（Ralph's）的配送服务来处理您本周的杂货采购吧。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。然后我们打包好，并在短短30分钟内送达，这样您就可以确信这就是您订购的商品。新鲜的杂货，以您的方式，通过拉尔夫的配送和自提。现在，您的第一笔配送或自提订单可以节省20美元。
Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拉尔夫，为每个人提供新鲜。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。